all right let's get to the draft teams
that need a strong
september chris i got a trivia question
for you there are two teams
that do not have a win in september
in the last two seasons name one of
those teams
oh gosh
i'm gonna it's not jacksonville i'm
gonna go with the jets
correct correct the jets and the broncos
the broncos wow september wins for the
broncos
all right um chris you win first pick
goes to you
teams that need a strong september all
right i'm gonna go to one with one that
hey listen it's close to my heart but
this is i think it's real
i mean i do i'm gonna go with the new
york giants i think they're one of those
teams that needs a strong september
you know one hey we know that you know
the joe
judge hiring last year a little
controversial
it's a huge year for daniel jones you
know people always on david gettleman
and all of those type of things like i i
feel like they're a team that needs to
get off to a good start to get some
confidence on the offensive side of the
ball especially with their quarterback
and win some games that way
daniel jones jason garrett second year
that offense
everything there you know people talking
about paying too much money for kenny
galladay
all of those type of things they're a
team that just needs to get some wins
and get some confidence and momentum
going like we talk about
so i'll take the giants first yeah i i
agree with you in that respect and as we
mentioned last hour there's a report
that the broncos will visit the giants
to start the season if they don't have
aaron rodgers
easier game for the giants to win if
they do have aaron rodgers if he gets
traded to denver which
i think is still a less than i'd say
less than 20
chance and that may be a little bit too
high of happening
uh then uh if it does happen much harder
to win
all right i'm going to start with the
jaguars team we spent a lot of time
talking about last hour
you've got a new coach who needs players
to buy in
and it's going to be a challenge for
urban meyer an urban meyer may
may lose twice as many games
in a month than he'd lose in a season at
ohio state
and i know he's done the mental
gymnastics and when you lose a game in
college
one loss completely destroys your season
and maybe you can lose two games
at most but you you know once you lose
that second game you're not going to win
the national championship
and the the walls are caving in on you
and the pressure is immense you got to
win every week
get back to me after you go 0-4 to start
your nfl career
because once those losses start to pile
up and
you're fighting harder to get the guys
in the locker room to hold it together
and you've talked in the past chris
about
the stress how it increases after oh and
two
oh and three the pressure the anxiety
everything to get that win it gets worse
and worse and worse and worse and this
is the guy we've seen
we've seen this guy cave under intense
pressure before
he he needs to get some wins out of the
gates he needs to get people
in that building to buy into what he's
doing and they need these young players
to come out of the gates and and build
some confidence yeah because if they can
then they can build more confidence as
the season unfolds yeah no i think
that's
they're definitely their team i had
written down for sure all the angles you
talked about i mean yeah it's a college
coach who's
you know probably selling a different
bill of goods as compared to maybe other
coaches in the nfl
all that trevor lawrence angle you want
to get him off on a good start
yeah get everything positive vibes there
in jacksonville i'm with you all
all the way i mean listen my next pick
is going to be a team that you just
brought up i mean
uh and and you know i forgot that they
were going to play the team i drafted
first but the broncos are the other team
i would i look at
yeah i mean again we we just talked
about in the trivia they haven't won a
game in september in two years
vic fangio you know it is that third
year now
where it's like okay what's where's the
improvement of the team what's gonna
what's gonna be better can we show it on
the field the roster looks better
we've seen inklings of looking better
but now it's time to get it done
and there's questions about drew locke
and that issue there a lot of people in
denver mad that the
broncos weren't more serious about
drafting a quarterback in the top ten
and everything like that so i look at
them as one of those teams to where
september can really dictate the year
for them if they go one and three
i don't know if they have the leadership
or anything like that to kind of fight
through it and come back
but if they can go in through it two and
two three and one
then like you've just talked about with
jacksonville you know you get guys to
start to believe and there's a common
goal
and you know it just the momentum builds
in a building and it's very real
so i'm gonna go with the broncos chris
here's the other side of it too you got
a new gm
with a hold over head coach no doubt and
vic vic fangio if he has a bad year
then there's gonna be a new coach in
denver next year because george payton
is going to want to hire his own guy
fangio's going to have to earn the job
beyond 2021
and if you have a bad september it's
going to be difficult to do and it's a
very difficult conference or division
and
and conference but especially the
division i'm gonna stay in the
conference and go to a different
division i'm gonna say the pittsburgh
steelers
when they go all in bring back ben yeah
here we go
we gotta run the ball we gotta show we
can come out and do what we did last
year they went 11-0 last year you can't
go two and two in september the year
after you went 11-0 and expect to be
better
you need to come out of the gates and
establish that yes
ben still has it that yes naji harris
was the right pick in round one
that yes the offensive line is working
and we we know one of the realities of
having
reduced off-season workouts reduced
training camp intensity it takes some
time
for the offensive line to get to where
it's going to be the steelers need to
crack that code
they need to hack that process they need
to get the offense moving
and they need to count on their defense
to do well enough to get those wins
in september so they can carry the
momentum into october and november
because this is the
all-in one last year with ben we think
we have a chance to win the super bowl
season for the steelers
what they do or don't do in september is
going to be critical to how that plays
out chris
right well uh i just uh was told that
they're playing the bills week one so
that's going to be a tough game
in buffalo so they they got a good
chance to start 0-1 right there but
either way that's going to be a fun
game to watch week one definitely um
yeah good pick
good pick by you though no doubt it's a
big year for them
and big ben and the new formula as far
as how they want to play on offense and
everything like that
uh so i i totally understand that um
i'm like torn here between like i i i'm
not gonna pick the jets
i you know it's there's a lot of newness
there oh yeah we want them to get off to
a good start but i don't think the
pressure's on them
i'm torn between like vegas and cincy a
little bit i'm going to go with
cincinnati here
and this one cincinnati is a team again
we've got to get some hope at the the
the first half of the season
one of these years and that hasn't
happened in the zac
taylor era yet i mean it's four four
eleven and one last year
two and 14 the year before and basically
a sense that
hey we're out of this thing by week five
or six
uh the last two years and now you got
joe burrow
who got hurt so that the coaches kind of
get blamed for that like oh you guys
didn't protect him
you know the roster does have some names
on there and some players now to where
you go
okay we we expect some better results
here in cincinnati
i look at them as a team that's you know
needs a favorable schedule
got to have something positive happen to
kind of jump start
that that momentum there in cincinnati
because i do think that's one of those
places where if it's a bad september
uh i you know people are going to start
jumping on the backs of all those people
in cincinnati
pete says that the bengals host the
vikings
to start the season
[Music]
the bengals host the vikings yes okay
after woody originally all right
joe i hope he can play are you sure they
host the vikings peter you're sure they
host the vikings can we check one more
time
okay um i i you know you gave me an idea
there
that i may not i've got my list i know
not only the raiders one
the raiders right i know yeah but but
we've been saying it for weeks now it's
put up or shut up time
three years for john gruden no playoff
appearances they can't
just stagger out of the gates they got
to come out and kick ass they got to go
three and one or better
in september i don't know pete do we do
they play at the bengals week one
no no no they're hosting the vikings too
but i i agree with you yeah they've got
to do it they've they've got they've got
to get off to a big start
right right i mean we still question
right i mean we're questioning a lot of
things there
you know oddly enough we're not
questioning the quarterback that's good
but i mean the o-line that's got people
you know questioning that what all the
things that went on in the off-season
you know the the the receivers and the
talk that you know mike mayek has talked
about henry ruggs has got to be better
some of these young guys got to start
coming you know rising to the top and
the same with the defensive side of the
ball so
i do think this is a year like you're
right people are going to be looking at
vegas pretty
pretty tightly by the way there's only
three games in september
this year uh unless you play the
thursday night game
in week four which is september 30. but
i generally
refer to it as the first four games of
the season i mentioned that because i
seriously considered
the patriots as a team that needs to
have a strong september because there's
just this sense of desperation and
urgency
there's a report from bleacher report
that
the patriots and the buccaneers play
week four oh week four to start october
or maybe that's when the lightning
strikes it could be it could be thursday
night i have a feeling
they're not going to put it on a
thursday night i have a feeling it's
going to be a 425 or a sunday night game
it's going to be uh one of the biggest
games of the year so
you know what we've heard in the past
from bill belichick and and as we study
the patriots it does take them some time
to get up to speed
um i want to see fans through that game
too i
i think i asked tom curran a couple of
weeks ago
would would the patriots be better off
with that game late in the year or early
in the year what do you think is it
better
week four or fourteen i think patriots i
i think it's better to just get it out
of the way
and get done with it and not have it
always like oh brady's coming to town
what are we gonna do what's the reaction
gonna be like you know the
organization's probably gonna do
something and show a video on you know
they're gonna honor him in some way too
i think that would be one you'd be
better off kind of getting it out of the
way early on in the season
and and back to like our crowd point we
talked about just like that's a game
where
damn do you want to see fans i mean that
might be weird
i mean literally brady might throw a
touchdown for the bucks and the stadium
might cheer
they might be like yes boo defense but
yes like how did you let him throw that
but yes
brady like it it'll really i think it'd
be a very interesting dynamic in that
stadium that night
they're not gonna boo-boos massachusetts
he might be able to lower the crowd in a
two-minute drill and literally like be
quiet and they might listen
on the opposing team's quarterback i
mean i really would love to see what
what they'll do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports